okay all right so Asher
yes Asher where'd you grow up were you
from I'm originally from Phoenix Arizona
my family from the Midwest but I live
with my dad when I was very young my
great-grandmother died and we moved into
her house in northern Arizona and never
left and how was your childhood abusive
but fun I was a skateboarder so I had
lots of fun so the turmoil at my home
being from a broken family and bouncing
back and forth to stepparents and
weekend dad and stuff like that sent me
to the street as a skateboarder and
that's what gave me my identity as a
young man because everybody looks for
something to attach themselves to I mean
if you have a good home life and so for
me I found that in the street and I
never turned back and so you came to LA
with a point I actually am state-raised
so I did my first prison term here and
cya when I was about 14 or 15 and I was
arrested in a Indio California crossing
the border in a stolen vehicle that I
was unaware of my friend said hey you
want to go to Riverside and I said yeah
that sounds great
and I fell asleep it was a long drive
and on the way back they said hey we got
pulled over
children cops it's uh your car you know
your juvenile you won't go to jail I
learned really quickly from that point
on you know that uh the law and me have
had a long relationship because I don't
go with the flow you know so whatever
somebody tells me to do I typically tend
to do the opposite where do you think
you got that personality trait my
grandmother
she was very stubborn she's an artist a
schoolteacher she made pottery and she's
actually the one that raised me so
eating vegetables drinking water being a
good-hearted person all those traits
come from my grandmother but
second that you go outside you have to
hide those things and bury them in order
for self-preservation and not
necessarily put on this facade of a
tough guy but you kind of put those
things to a side so I'll say I'm split
personality but I'm a chameleon in the
sense where I can change who I am
sometimes on an instant but only for
safety reasons perhaps you know but my
good nature comes from my grandmother so
you have you have kids a euro yes um I
have five children and my oldest
daughter is in her mid-20s and her name
is Ashley I had her when I was very
young and at that time graffiti was
something that was a big deal to me
along with skateboarding so I started
writing my daughter's name as Asher as a
way to show her how much that I cared
about her and so as she was growing up
she would see this around the city in
around town and her friends when she got
older would say oh look there's your
look look there's your knee your dad
loves you so much
he rents her name and she's the polar
opposite of me when I say that I mean
successful smart intelligent and not a
vandal and so when you asked her her
name she says ash when she signs her
name ash but Asher is me and Ashley is
my daughter all of my children not only
like graffiti or either do it themselves
but they don't have a real love for it
it's just something that they enjoy but
I have five children and a grandchild
and I couldn't be happier did you raise
them yes except for my youngest two I
have been incarcerated but from birth
until my daughter was 16 she never went
to daycare she never went to Grandma and
Grandpa's I became a tattooer simply for
the fact to be able to facilitate being
a stay-at-home parent and so my
first two kids are very lucky to have
had me as such a big influence in their
life and I think the reason why there's
such good successful people and not like
me is a big testament to that so so what
do you call yourself a tiger fear um I'm
one of Los Angeles California's most
prolific graffiti writers because not
only do i dominate the visual supremacy
of downtown LA with my block letters and
I paint in broad daylight but I don't
hide who I am and I don't hide my face
because my grandmother told me when I
was very young if you have to sneak to
do something it's wrong and so this is
very confusing to me because this now
means that smoking marijuana cussing and
spray-painting is something that society
might deem to be negative but I don't
want to offend my grandmother and so
she's like well then I wouldn't do it
then if you're concerned about offending
me but this is Who I am
well then you should be who you are well
now I'm confused so how do I be Who I am
and not offend her so what she's trying
to say is you just have to do what makes
you happy and so I decided that what I'm
doing is not a crime if I don't believe
it's a crime so by changing the color of
the surface of millimeter thick might be
something that society deems not only a
crime but a felonious crime based upon
how much property damage and then can
result in not only incarceration but
community service restitution and even
embarrassment being dragged to your
court and all kinds of things simply
because you're expressing yourself in a
way that's not conducive to what society
deems but this is very strange because
if you paint a mural then you will be
not only celebrated but you will be
financially compensated so if I choose
to go and put my art here that's not on
somebody's personal property I can be
arrested and I just think that that is
ridiculous and [ __ ] and I don't agree
with it because Society has so many
problems but yet if I go up and put my
message or my name or whatever I want
and that's deemed illegal but then
there's a sign and then there's all
these other things from the city and
promotions for politicians and everybody
trying to get elected and all of that
is not only illegal in its own right but
its eye pollution and it's something
that we don't want to see Calvin Klein
ads and things like that los angeles
california's diversity is based upon the
fact that not only do we celebrate
graffiti here but when you get
well-known enough you're actually
elevated to celebrity status which is
kind of a conundrum when you think about
it if something is illegal and then
you're really good at it then now you're
an artist and you go the art world and
make lots of money but how do you bridge
the gap from being a tagger and
something illegal and to make it into
mainstream well I have found that
majority of people sell out I guess is
what you would call it they stop doing
graffiti if they ever did do illegal
graffiti like myself they don't do it
like I do they sneak around at nighttime
they wear hoods and masks they get drunk
they get liquid courage they go into
train yards they get their friends
around them because they're scared to be
in these bad neighborhoods every day
that I paint in downtown Los Angeles I'm
going to be confronted by somebody in a
negative way and I know and understand
this and this is a risk and I'm willing
to take but whether it's an 18th Street
gang member telling me that this is his
territory and that he's working here or
a security guard a police officer a
business owner another graffiti writer
anybody I'm going to run into one of
them guaranteed but the what separates
me I don't [ __ ] run ever
I own that [ __ ] and so when somebody
confronts you not only do they not
understand why are you not running but
they respect you for that
even if it is their building and you
turn around and talk to him and tell him
why even if he doesn't agree with it
he's not gonna punch you shoot you
because not only am i articulate and I'm
telling you exactly what I'm doing
this is the first time that he's ever
spoken or confronted what he would
consider a tagger or graffiti writer and
this guy is
not what he fought and so my appearance
and my art looks abrasive and I totally
understand that because it's supposed to
but it's a reflection of who I am and
where I'm from so doing what I do here
wouldn't make sense in another city or
another place because not only would not
be celebrated it'd be used as negative
but here people around the world look at
what I do here and copy it around the
world so to me that lets me know not
only do I have influence but because I'm
in Los Angeles California it makes it
extremely different nobody cares if you
paint in the middle of the wilderness in
Colorado
nobody gives a [ __ ] if you go and do
graffiti in the back of your mom's
backyard on a shed no matter how
impressive it is because there was no
risk involved so for me that I think is
one of the biggest things is that not
only am I gonna possibly lose my freedom
which I have getting beaten severely
which recently this was a result of some
poor decisions on my behalf directly
caused from painting and then the step
guys right now yes the black guys I was
in a hospital for a good day and a half
they had to do a lot of tests I had some
severe bleeding issues not only in my
face but other areas of the body but I'm
not sure how good you can see these
scars but um the one right here but this
was um some of these teeth this one
along the top was my head being split
open them with a pipe this one across
the forehead I was beaten with hammers
in an alley not too far from here
because these are different these are
all different instances but these are
all arm injuries directly related to
graffiti because somebody in my opinion
did something that they shouldn't have
basically disrespected me went over me
wrote some stupid message that was not
conducive to reality they see me they
fall down really fast I leave very
quickly and they tell
that's been a repetitive cycle
throughout my life and at some point
most graffiti writers at about from the
age of 14 to 20 they come face with life
decisions which is I got a job I got
arrested I have a kid this is juvenile
and I can't continue this and so they
stopped or here in Los Angeles this is
something different from a lot of places
they write graffiti in the neighborhood
where they're from but then the gangs
are so deep in these areas where
graffiti is predominate that the gangs
confront the people doing graffiti and
then now they tell them hey not only can
you not do that here but you're
disrespecting us because this is our
territory so about you writing your name
you're saying that this is your
territory so instead of us [ __ ] you
up because we know who you are and where
you live we can just allow you to keep
doing graffiti but now you're gonna
write the gang name because you're from
this hood anyway so the little kid who
had no intention of ever being a gang
member because he was a little writer or
tagger or an artist is now a
full-fledged gang member because he
didn't have a choice he didn't want to
but now that he is he still gets to
practice that act of graffiti and
there's a lot of gangs here in Los
Angeles that started as taggers and they
their gang name is a tagger name but now
it's a full-on game and so so you've
been arrested um you know up until
recently I had never been arrested and
prosecuted for graffiti I've been
stopped I don't I get stopped almost on
a daily basis and people don't
understand this they want to know well
how do you not get arrested Oh trust him
believe me I do get arrested I've never
been prosecuted
they've never filed charges they've
dismissed him they let me go I talked my
way out of it I you know things of that
nature but just recently I was arrested
on East LA Soto and Olympic underneath
the bridge painting and I was with a
group of people that were from out of
town and they got obviously
a little agitated or not agitated but
they got a little concerned when the
police came and I said don't worry about
it I'll take care of it
and when I went and approached the
police it's because I deal with this on
a daily basis and I thought that it
wasn't gonna be a bad situation
unfortunately I was wrong
they told me to get down on the ground
and I was ultimately arrested for felony
vandalism and when I went to court the
case was not filed and I was very happy
but I'm currently out on bail for an
assault charge and I got out of prison
on my last case for aggravated assault
which is the exact same charges I'm on
bail for now but when I got arrested for
graffiti you cannot get arrested while
you're out on bail which I did so I
bailed out on that one before my other
bail cuff any kid find out but when I
went to court they dropped it well I got
a letter in the mail yesterday they just
filed it so not only they just filed the
graffiti charge that I thought was drops
this incident with the black eyes I got
another assault case and so now I'm on
bail for assault case felony vandalism
got an assault case pending all three of
these pending and I still do graffiti
every day so let's say I'm a business
owner I rent a space somewhere and I am
proud of my new business I mean yes we
clean it up and make it perfect and
that's my new place of business and then
one day I show up for work and there's
graffiti all over the building
how do you justify that it depends I
didn't I didn't approve it I didn't want
absolutely and so um every graffiti
writer has certain things that they're
willing to respect me personally I
respect people's personal property I
would never write on somebody's vehicle
or their home now
you mentioned a business it depends on
where that business is located if you
are in downtown LA or in downtown Skid
Row your shits fair game and the reason
being is because it's such a bad
neighborhood that this artwork
whether it's gang writing traditional
graffiti propaganda
huit pasting road signs there's gonna be
some sort of graffiti on your building
whether I do it or somebody else does it
but if you have a new building in a nice
area I would never touch that building
and the reason being is because not only
am i a businessman and I have my own
business and my own studio
I wouldn't want somebody to do that to
my [ __ ] but the thing of it is
everybody's different so when I was
painting on a business very near here
the business owner came out and in the
commission of doing this he threatened
me with a gun and said what in the world
would possess you to stand here so
brazenly and disrespect me in my
business and I said I beg to differ
what's your name and he didn't want to
shake my hand but it caused him to pause
and so on I asked him what his name was
I said my name is Asher and I'm actually
your neighbor and I live right down the
street and I have a studio across the
street and your building was covered
with garbage and so I was covering it up
in a way that I thought looked better
but I didn't mean to offend you and you
don't own this building but I understand
that you own it and now that I'd met you
I won't continue to do this but since I
started you should at least allow me to
finish and he said absolutely not
because I have this gun doesn't mean
that I'm afraid to use it
but I don't like my neighbors whatsoever
so please do it next door so I just
changed my camera that I was recording
and I shifted it and I went and finished
it next door so I mean it kind of just
depends on a case-by-case basis and I
think and my view of things
it's okay but it's because it's already
there it's already going to happen but I
definitely would not want it on my home
or my business a school or a church you
know things of that nature but that's me
I'm in my 40s I'm an old-school guy but
new kids new people you have to give
respect in order to receive it and if
they're from a street if they're from a
gang and a crew that does this graffiti
and they're proud of being vandals then
that's what they want to do the point is
to vandalize [ __ ] you know it's because
they're seeking an identity and that's
what it is about is [ __ ] the system
stick it to the man we don't pay taxes
we steal our supplies we don't abide by
rules in this society because it's a
bunch of [ __ ] and lies and we're artists
and we're young and we're free and we're
[ __ ] wild and we can do whatever we
choose but let's just be honest that
self-destructive behavior is only gonna
get you so far and so I've been dealing
with this for a long time and people ask
me why do you keep doing this like you
have children you have grandchildren
you're successful you're celebrated why
haven't you started doing something else
why haven't you stuck and what do you
get out of this headaches headaches but
it's my passion and Who I am and I don't
believe that I'm gonna perish that I'm
gonna go to jail even though I'm a pink
petal when I'm state-raised and this is
who I am
I used to feel that this was negativity
but now I realize this is not only Who I
am but it brought me to this point
and so if I didn't go through those
negativity in those trials of prison
especially out as a young man I wouldn't
be where I am now but unfortunately for
me I'm still carrying a lot of that
misperception of masculinity so god
forbid somebody step on my shoes or bump
into me because I'm gonna assault you
immediately without thinking about it
and then immediately after doing so I'm
gonna realize oh [ __ ] you messed up and
so when I was young my dad used to
always ask me even though we didn't live
together he would always say what's the
matter with you what's the matter with
you you don't
think what's the matter with you and it
got to the point where I started
thinking there was something wrong with
me you know like maybe I do have a
mental problem because if I punch this
guy or if I paint on this guy's building
and I get arrested or I go to jail
that's not only not smart but that's
self-destructive so maybe he's right but
in reality it wasn't until I started
paying severe consequences like going to
jail like losing my freedom like being
alienated from my family that I started
to slowly think about things but now
fast forward 25 years later why am I
still doing it
I don't believe I'm doing anything wrong
I think society is the one with the
problem
and I think that when I had my first
solo art show in a gallery in downtown
Los Angeles this year and I make an
extensive amount of money and then I
start traveling the world now
everybody's gonna say oh look this is my
nephew this is my brother oh look how
proud I am of my family member he's so
successful and only because a monetary
value or because I'm doing it in a
gallery so if I'm a successful tattooer
instead of painting the street or if I'm
instead of doing canvases so I choose my
canvas and I choose my art and where I
choose to put it but you're only
celebrated in certain ways and I think
that is uh not only ridiculous but I'm
willing to deal with the consequences
because authenticity cannot be faked or
duplicated and real will always rise to
the top so some people aren't the best
hustlers some people can't sell their
art some people have the best art
ability but don't have the hustle or the
knowledge of finances my thing is I have
no [ __ ] interest in those things I'm
a minimalist and I love being out here
and the fact that I'm not doing life in
prison the fact that I can walk outside
my studio on Skid Row and for the price
of a dollar can of spray paint paint
anywhere in Los Angeles knowing it'll
reach to the far ends of the world via
the internet I'm the happiest guy on
earth I might not have a dollar to my
name at some point I might be facing
over a decade in prison single all these
things against me but in reality I'm the
happiest that I've ever been because I'm
living my dream and I don't care what
anybody says I'm a part of history and
not only am I in the history books I'm
in the concrete in downtown Los Angeles
that [ __ ] is never going anywhere I'm in
the history books I'm on the rooftop of
this building in front of the street
downtown everywhere oh gee a sure Lok's
downtown Skid Row Los Angeles California
watch out for me
all right Asher thank you very much
thank you
you